computers have become truly incredible
we are walking around with the super
computers in our pocket how amazing is
that so it is disappointing that the way
we use computers the way we interact
with them
hasn't she really changed in last 50
years we still use the mouse and
keyboard for clicking on screens and the
buttons mobile phones are saying with
just using finger instead of the mouse
so is that it is that how future looks
like we're gonna be stuck in the screens
with our faces not seeing the world
around us that's not the future I
imagine them the future I'm attracted to
what I'm being always interested is
things physical things we use everyday
like things on this table that family
doesn't pay attention to things tell our
story they tell who we are they tell a
lot about us
let me give you example these are
photographs of things that person
touched during 24 hours what can you
tell about him he loves his motorcycle
my biggest thing his picture what can
you tell about this girl she spent all
her time on the beach there's a
surfboard she lives by the sea what can
you tell about this guy he's a chef look
at all the ingredients he touched during
the day while he was preparing the food
and computer is a tiny part of his life
these sad things in the corner so if
we're using things all the time and this
is part a big part of our lives
can things become a way for us to
interact with our digital life can the
world become your interface and that was
my idea I've been working for 20 years
on my idea is that another things are
actually digital lives you don't need to
have screens and keyboards and Mouse's
you can interact with your digital life
just by using things you use every day
and to realize this idea you need to
solve three big challenges let me tell
you about them the first one obviously
is it even possible how can you take an
everyday thing you use every day and
turn it in computer interface now I was
inspired by the book hackers I read when
I was a teenager and the central idea of
this book one of the essential ideas of
this book is that you can change the
purpose of things by inventing new
technology then hacking into things and
changing them so I've been thinking what
kind of technology I can invent so that
I can hack into things you use every day
and make them interactive so when I was
working on this they invented this
sensor which injects structured
electrical field into objects and told
them and gesture interfaces so this door
knob unmodified can become a gesture
sensor you can know how attachments can
feel how touching
it made circle what can i grasp and this
doorknob is unmodified there's nothing
about special about doorknobs anything
can become interactive what about plants
so the plants are interesting because
with plants that can actually know where
you touching you see the line moving up
and down to the image and I can change
the musical interface now we do have
also a practical applications iCalendar
plant for those who obsess about
verticality we can give things a
personality so in this particular
example the orchid
can communicate to you through images
and sounds it doesn't like to be touched
so it's krita's electrical images on
hissing at you we can also give what
this plant for example is is more
Abbasid snake plants and it's likes
playing you it engages you so everything
can be different and everything can be
represent what fits feels so everything
can be hacked ever all the things
including your body in this example we
talk to your body so you can measure how
you fold in your hands and then using
your hand gestures to control something
else so if you don't want to listen to
music for thousands of times just simply
can cover your ears to turn it off so
everything can be hacked and research is
important but the second challenge we
have is how can we go from R&D and
prototypes to real products how can we
make a real things that are also
interfaces and they may ask yourself who
do this Silicon Valley is it do shenzhen
that the charge there that the world of
things is huge every year apparel
industry places hundred fifty billion
garments in comparison technology
industry only makes 1.4 billion phones
the world of things is much bigger than
the world of technology we can't the
technology world cannot change the world
of things instead we need to create
technology which change makers of things
people who make your chairs and calls
and everything else into makers of smart
things enable them to do that so today's
challenge we came up with very simple
kind of idea and challenge Kim a tailor
make a wearable now we don't want to
take a failure and turn the tale and
electrical engineer
we don't we'd still want to have some
tales around but we would like to do
create technology which looks fields and
behaves like a raw material used by the
tailor to make their clothes for example
a touch panel made for a tailor would
look like this
textiles we can cut it with scissors and
sew it in at the same time has to retain
the performance the way to make this
textile panel touch panel also require a
very different approach than from making
consumer electronics in our case we had
to go to mountains of Tokyo to small
factory which is making key morning on
four generations
we worked with my collaborators who were
not engineers it was an artisan who
knows how to make things in an artist
who knows how to make things beautiful
working with them we created one of the
best yarns in the world which is
consists of thin metallic alloys wrapped
around with polyester fibers and cotton
fibers these yarns were made on the same
machines which we were making yarns for
kimonos for generations well into this
yarns and give them to the factory which
is making making textiles and we wore
our smart textile using regular machines
in a variety of colors and materials and
we gave those textile to a tailor and
Savile Row in London so tailors a
traditionalists particular in Savile Row
they don't use computers they don't use
machines they use hands and they cut
they feed their products on a human body
not on 3d avatars technology is not a
part of the vocabulary but they are
modern people they know how to use
technology so if technology can be
formed and shaped like a button like a
textile like something they can use they
absolutely can make a wearable a garment
which can place a phone call so now
we've proven that you can actually make
a wearable not by the chemistry not by
electronic company but a by by the
tailor we worked with the colour
interbred with the Levi's our partners
in our neighbors to make a real product
and this product is this jacket I'm
wearing right now you can buy it on sale
and was made in the same factories which
made all their products and you have
noticed is that being controlling my my
my my presentation from the jacket from
the sleeve of the jacket I do like the
go forward now this your backward and of
course I can do more things it's not
just a control presentation you cannot
control my navigation control my my
music but most importantly it stays the
jacket it stays a thing which makes me
look you know great that's the most
important thing so um it's okay so we
prove we can turn things into interfaces
we prove that these things can be made
by makers of things and not by
technology companies I look awesome
are we done not yet the third challenge
how can we scale how can we go from one
product to many products and that will
be doing working right now let me tell
you how we're gonna do this the first of
all I want to make myself clear
I am NOT talking about Internet of
Things I'm not talking about creating
another gadget you get bored with and
throw in the back of your drawer and
forget about it I'm talking about
foundational important principle which
guides my work technology has to make
existing things better
it's Maydan better by connecting them to
your digital life and adds new
usefulness a new functionality when
remaining the same original purpose not
changing it this jacket I'm wearing can
control my mobile phone and presentation
by this remains a jacket that means that
once we start making all things
interactive and connected everything
would have its own set of chairs
displays all sensors specific for those
things a payoff front issue does not
need it have a touch sensor why would
they have a tie stance on pair of shoes
you have a sensor we should measure your
running performance or knee impact while
remaining the great pair of shoes makers
of things will have to start thinking
what kind of digital functionality they
have to offer to their consumers they
will have to become service providers
or they McGavin irrelevant we will have
to provide create a service ecosystem
just like we've done for mobile phones
where you have an apps and service and
everything else and sometimes you still
making phone call now to make the second
system possible we have the voice
fragmentation we have to avoid different
interfaces for different people for
different things we have to create
uniform user experience and for that
reason we have to create a single
computing platform which powers all
those things what will be platform going
to be I think the house is obvious it's
a cloud a cloud computing now you cannot
connect things directly to cloud
obviously so you have to do you have to
develop a small device which can be
plugged into all the things and make
them connected to the cloud to unlock
their potential and add new
functionality so let me show for the
first time the real device which we've
built we are sure this for the first
time that's how it looks like and
there's a small device which will be
connected to things we pull we want to
make smart and connected interactions
how it's going to work so on the back
you have a little some some few
electrodes so when you plug them into
different things like here the device
would recognize where you plug in them
and then reconfigure itself to enable
specific functionality for this
particular thing we would like to give
this device to makers of things be able
to make your clothing and furniture so
they can use it just like they use a
button or a zipper and what's they gonna
make with them it's up to them we don't
want to dictate the use cases we would
like to let people who make those things
artists and designers brands and
craftsmen to imagine and create this new
world where things are connected and
have us all this new exciting digital
functionality we don't need keyboards
and screens and Mouse's to interact with
your computer so I've been working on
this idea for 20 years and now it's
taking shape and as it taking shape what
we are realizing that I always saw them
working on computer interfaces I always
thought myself as interaction designer
but I'm realizing
that I'm not building interface but I
realized that me and my team we're
building new kind of computer an ambient
computer thank you
[Applause]
[Music]